one simple step firms can take is make
sure that people that are getting paid a
lot of money say more than a million or
two that a big chunk of that money is
deferred that's gonna change the whole
ballgame because the money has to be
deferred with what they call clawback
which means they can get it back if I
lose it all so that guy who's making ten
million a year selling credit default
swaps if we're gonna keep five million
of it in escrow for ten years and with
the right to go back and get it if he
starts losing money then we're gonna
give people the right incentives not to
take so much risk the same with the
mortgage brokers that we're selling
people mortgages they couldn't afford we
we shouldn't pay them on each mortgage
they write they should they should have
what they call skin in the game where it
they've got to reimburse us if the guy
who sold the mortgage defaults and so I
think that there are lessons that the
financial services industry can learn
and as I said they should either
aggressively take these steps on their
own or expect Congress time